imagine a world where affordable
healthcare is available to everyone
where your health doesn't depend on your
wealth I earned barely 100 rupees a day
how could I afford it and we're being
healthier makes you wealthier health
really is at this Center of development
it's a transformative idea and it's
called universal healthcare the strength
of a Nation lies in the health of its
citizens for decades most of the rich
world has taken it for granted but for
poorer countries Affordable Health Care
can still sound like pie in the sky and
yet it's more realistic than you think
it can be done at all income levels so
how can developing countries whatever
their means pay for and deliver
Universal Health Care
[Music]
thank you
nebron his father to 10 year old Puri
but in another world he might never have
enjoyed fatherhood
back in the late 1990s narong was
diagnosed with chronic kidney failure
age just 20. my
um
a shopkeeper did not qualify for
HealthCare coverage
like most Thai people
in desperate need of a kidney transplant
costing nearly eight thousand dollars
his family were forced to rely on loans
foreign
and his family learned he needed a
second kidney transplant
which would have meant Financial ruin
but this time everything was different
the state picked up the bill
um
today more than 99 of Thailand's
population has access to Affordable
Health Care so what brought about such
drastic change it became their key
campaign promise for the upcoming
general election in the early 2000s a
new Thai government became one of the
first developing countries to treat
their population to Universal Health
Care the policy plugged the previous
gaps in coverage making Affordable
Health Care available to all Thai
citizens rich or poor no country reaches
this Nevada perfect Universal Health
Coverage but Thailand took a huge leap
during that period Robert Yates advises
developing countries on the rollout of
Universal Health Care a policy that need
not be The Preserve of rich countries
universal
health coverage is everyone getting all
the health services they need without
suffering financial hardship obviously
it depends on a country's level of
wealth as to what package of services
you can provide to everyone even
low-income countries have at times been
able to introduce a Universal Health
System
so our other developing countries
following in Thailand's footsteps
the good news is that Global HealthCare
coverage people accessing essential
Services has improved
the bad news is this is only half the
battle far too many people are still
having to pay unaffordable and crippling
costs
the proportion of households spending
over 10 percent of their income on
health has risen by 40 since 2000.
this isn't true Universal care which
urgently needs administering in higher
doses across the world what you want to
move away from is out of pocket spending
you know sort of people buying and
selling some Services which is a
wretched way to to fund a health system
without that Financial Protection then a
lot of poor people will never Access to
Health Services
so what needs to change for more
countries to be able to cough up for
Affordable Health Care like Thailand
the answer hinges on public financing or
how countries extract the money to pay
for it
[Music]
usually three sources provide the
necessary cash injections
there's mandatory taxes collected in the
workplace known as social insurance
contributions General taxation with a
slice of all tax receipts earmarked for
health care and other state income like
selling natural resources
countries tend to prescribe all three
but the precise dose depends on their
circumstances like the makeup of their
economy and their working population
[Music]
it sounds all well and good but what
about the poorest countries with limited
income and few workers in the formal
economy who can pay taxes
one nation has led the way here with a
transformation that would have been
Unthinkable some 25 years ago
more than 500 putsis were hacked to
death here among the pews a gruesome
testimony to what amounts took the
world's latest display of ethnic
cleansing Luanda is Infamous for the
genocide which tore the country apart in
the mid-1990s
but it was this Darkest Hour which
sparked the introduction of universal
healthcare
since universal healthcare was rolled
out in 2004 infant mortality has dropped
by 59
maternal mortality by 67 percent
and today the national scheme covers
around 90 percent of rwandans and pays
for at least 90 percent of their medical
costs
it's an extraordinary turnaround and the
financial remedy lies in Innovative
Grassroots funding
what's known as a community Insurance
scheme the payment for insurance is not
the same for everybody a poor person
will contribute what they can afford to
contribute which ensures that they are
not impoverished whilst the ones who can
afford more will contribute more this
community Insurance model doesn't raise
Enough by itself the pot is topped up
with other Central funds including
development aid from foreign donors is
not a perfect model by any means but it
could be copied by more countries
the trick is successfully pooling
different sources of funding
allowing more Healthcare to be provided
at lower cost than if people are left to
purchase care themselves
it's this principle of pooling that
ensures everyone is covered
vital that that you have a pool
financing system otherwise it will only
be rich people who will get Services if
you want it that health services are
being allocated and consumed according
to need then it has to be a publicly
financed Health System whereby wealthy
healthy members of society subsidize the
services for the sick and the poor
reforming how health services are paid
for can only get a country so far making
sound decisions about how this public
money is spent is just as important to
delivering Universal Health Care
for this countries need to triage their
health spending and invest in the care
which saves and improves the greatest
number of lives this varies from country
to country but all services should be
assessed for their impact
value for money
and feasibility
[Music]
in Thailand it's Dr Judd tamatatari's
job to help decide what services make
the cut
foreign
is Thailand's commitment to this
strategic approach that ensures it gets
better bang for its Buck than the
world's wealthiest Nation America
on the provision of Essential Health
Services the two countries score evenly
but Thailand spends around 700 per
person to achieve this while the U.S one
of the only developed countries where
Healthcare is mostly left to the free
market
spends almost eleven thousand dollars
per person
like other developing countries which
have successfully implemented Universal
Health Care Thailand has adapted its
priorities initially it focused on basic
treatments for infectious diseases and
child and maternal health
since then the needle has moved with the
country becoming richer and life
expectancy higher Now Thailand
prioritizes managing chronic diseases
like cancer heart disease and kidney
failure
today narong has a monthly checkup
appointment at his local hospital
it's been four years since he received
his second kidney transplant fully paid
for under Thailand's Universal coverage
scheme
like many no wrong benefits from
Thailand's focus on Primary Health Care
which manages illnesses within
communities
this focus on Primary Care is a core
part of universal healthcare and key to
delivering it around the world
the provision of care in the community
is really important it makes it easier
for community members to access
it is cheaper
it is provided by somebody that they
know it means that they they can get it
as early as possible Primary Health Care
is really the driver of the universal
health coverage
universal healthcare can make a country
not only healthier but wealthier too
when people like narong live longer
healthier lives countries reap the
rewards of having more productive
populations
foreign
rather than saving for a healthcare
emergency would-be patients can spend
their earnings boosting the economy
and there are other benefits too there's
very strong evidence that providing
people with Universal Health Services
makes more people inclined to pay their
taxes and it just raises this
expectation you know that spending money
the taxes are a good thing
[Music]
and one of the biggest advantages of all
comes from minimizing the devastating
impact of Health crises
foreign
looking back through history that it's
actually been at times of Crisis that a
number of these great Universal Health
reforms have occurred Britain introduced
universal healthcare following a war
Thailand during an economic crisis and
Rwanda after a genocide
the recent Global pandemic should be the
wake-up call to roll out universal
healthcare in more countries
I'm Tom standage Deputy editor of The
Economist and editor of the world ahead
to read more of our future gazing
coverage click on the link thanks for
watching and don't forget to subscribe